you all know michelle malkin is a fierce
champion of free speech particularly
online where she's a pioneering
entrepreneur well tonight she's gonna
shed light on the dark forces behind
organized efforts to silence
conservatives michelle malkin welcome
back to the angle great to see you I
think it's so important Michelle for the
people watching Fox tonight to see and
understand what this all is really all
about and I want to start with George
Soros George Soros has funded left-wing
groups as you've pointed out the Center
for American Progress I think we have a
graphic can we see it please the color
of change people for the American Way
Media Matters Action Network connected
with Media Matters there we have all
those organizations tell us Michelle
which are the worst offenders and
enemies of free thought free expression
well Media Matters has been at the
forefront of the speech squelches who
are highly organized incredibly
disciplined and obviously deeply funded
not only by George Soros but a number of
left-wing foundations and I think it's
really important to note that so many of
these outfits are tax-exempt that they
enjoy so much largesse as a result of
IRS laws and that under democratic
administrations the definitions of 501 C
3 s and C 4 s have been stretched so
that these blatantly partisan political
organizations have cast themselves as
somehow educational or social welfare
groups so you have Media Matters that's
gone after every prominent conservative
effective voice in the public square and
they'll use any pretext these people do
this for full-time living and as a
result it is undeniable Laura and you
and I have fought in this arena for so
many years now in both talk radio on
broadcast and yes on social media where
it has been so important for independent
conservative voices to get their
messages out and we know
that that the encroachment of these
sensors and these bullies in the public
square has left a undeniable cloud over
the First Amendment and free expression
and Michelle people say well this is all
this is all the free marketplace of
ideas and you know everyone else is you
know if they want to complain about
someone who said something they do that
and that's part of the democratic
process too and so each side has their
own opinions and one side wants to you
know you know whatever they doing they
have these corporations that just wilt
though that is will they get a hundred
emails from some left-wing activists and
they will meanwhile millions of
conservatives like are you kidding me it
makes no sense yeah and in some cases
the supposed backlash that that elicits
this feckless response from corporations
that just don't want any bad publicity
sometimes constitutes a couple of tweets
right and so then you have the Media
Matters and color of changes of the
world that exploit their social justice
status I mean they have an absolute
immunity shield to go after
conservatives for expressing mainstream
thought and opinion and that sort people
need to know about the agenda the agenda
of these left-wing character assassins
is to enlarge analyze your mainstream
thought awesome we're gonna be right
back Michelle Malkin